um good morning everyone
um
it's lovely to attend my first ndc um
today and get to speak to you all about
design
um
so
design for developers is a bit of a
whistle-stop tour
um of design principles and applications
especially relevant to the web um so i
wanted to write this talk
um because i've worked with a lot of
front-end developers in the past
who've asked me to share some tips and
tricks
um on how they can create better designs
sometimes it's because they've wanted to
create designs for themselves
or projects they're working on and
sometimes it's because they've had no
other choice but to be the designer
and so whoever you are and whatever you
do i'm very grateful you're here
um so who am i
i'm lex lofthouse i use she her pronouns
and my handle on almost everything is at
lofty loftio
and i'm a designer
i have been for over 10 years now
um i originally studied graphic design
up in scotland and i moved down to
nottingham in 2011 to pursue a career in
design
i now work at a digital agency called
enzyme who are based in nottingham
um there and throughout my career i've
specialized in web design but also brand
and print and all sorts of other kind of
design as well
so
starting with a preface um but i feel
like this is important
i've got an hour here so i'm not going
to teach you everything that i've
learned about design over the last kind
of decade um and it's not a
comprehensive overview of everything it
takes to be a designer but i think we
all know that
i'm also not going to teach any
code-based technique i don't really code
very well um most of the time i hand my
designs over to front-end developer so
who am i to tell you how to do that
um so what this talk is i'm going to be
going through some fundamental design
principles first of all
some common design elements and tips on
how to implement those and lastly i'm
going to go through some kind of before
and after examples on how we can refine
existing designs for the front end as
well so let's get started
so i want to start with the basics so
this is principles of design and that
are important to follow so
there is no real law on how many
principles of design there are and some
will say there is three four five six
seven
eight and so on um but i feel like four
is probably enough
and relevant enough for you to consider
when it comes to designing for the web
so those four elements are
hierarchy
proximity
contrast
and balance so let's have a look into
what each of these mean
so hierarchy similar to how we think of
hierarchy in business and society and
nature
it's a system in which things are
arranged based on their
importance so in design we achieve this
visually
by creating elements and putting them in
a clear order of priority
and so in development as well
a common way we see this is with
headings for example
you know h1 h2 h3 usually visually
styled
to follow that naming convention in
order of hierarchy
it's a relatively simple
principle to implement within design
because there are quite a few ways to do
it
one of the most common being scale for
example the biggest thing on the page is
going to be the most important
so
that's principle one our second is
proximity
so proximity is part of a larger set of
principles called gestalt principles
so early in the 20th century
psychologists studied how humans made
sense of the world
and decided how we
decide that things belong together um so
they found that the proximity of objects
had a big part in that so
when it comes to design
um for proximity we look at the content
and we understand the relationship that
these pieces of content have to each
other and we place them together in a
way that makes sense
so the distance between objects or the
lack of
really helps us understand
contents connection to each other
helps us group things on a page or
screen for example in order to
demonstrate that
so to use text as an example again
if we have a heading
and a paragraph of text sitting closely
underneath that you can probably safely
say those things belong together and
that heading is probably introducing
what that piece of copy says
so
proximity
next principle is contrast so
contrast is a principle we use to
emphasize objects in our design
this is achieved by having things be the
opposite to each other or close enough
to appear opposite
and we use that to highlight certain
elements against one another for
emphasis so contrast again
can be used in different ways um
sometimes we use it for emphasis um and
in some ways that kind of relates back
to the hierarchy principle too
we might really want to highlight
something on the page by contrasting it
with something else making it stand out
other times contrast is just a crucial
part of the interface um
again if we go back to text
white text on a black background or vice
versa um just makes stuff really easy to
read and that's contrast
so it doesn't always apply to color
either it can be achieved in other ways
such as using kind of juxtaposing font
choices
different scales and shapes
the key thing about contrast is that it
helps the user know where to look it
creates a form of visual impact that
draws the eye
okay last principle
is balance
so there's two types of balance
when we talk about design principles
there is symmetrical balance and there's
asymmetrical balance
so both rely on elements working
alongside each other
and balance really provides
a structure to your layout it's weight
distributed
um across your design by the placement
of elements
so
symmetrical balance means you've got a
design that's quite evenly displayed
often with a kind of invisible center
line down the middle um and this relies
on elements being equal to each other on
both sides it's like a balance that
scales
um
it's
quite a satisfactory and consistent
layout and it's quite easy to get right
asymmetrical balance on the other hand
is a bit more about tension
elements kind of offset each other a
little more
and it has a kind of unequal weight
it offers a bit more of a dynamic layout
feeling of movement but it's a little
trickier to get right
so
those are our four design principles and
the idea is to always kind of keep these
in mind um they're the kind of key to
creating a good design um so when you're
working on design keep these at the back
of your mind if we're talking in terms
of lego these are kind of like the
instructions
and what i'm going to move on to next is
the actual lego blocks
so that is the design elements is what
i'm going to call them um
the bits
that you need to build the layout
so again keeping this simple let's split
this into four key areas
we've got typography
we've got color
imagery
and layout so these four visual design
elements implemented alongside our
principles
are the kind of key to creating a great
interface so
four principles
four elements easy peasy
um so i want to run through what each of
these are and some good tips um
to use for each of these so let's start
with typography what is typography it is
the art and technique of arranging type
so
step one in typography is fonts
so a lot goes into typography and it
isn't just limited to your font choices
but it does include them so it's a good
place to start
so depending on what you're working on
you might not need to choose fonts you
might be really lucky and not have to
choose them yourself and you might be
working with a brand that already has
that set but you may be faced with a
choice yourself so how do you do this
typically i'd suggest
choosing a font pairing for your project
so
this is what i would call easy mode for
choosing fonts choose one font for
headings and choose one font for body
copy
so for headings you can be a bit braver
with this choice this usually applies to
content that is shorter larger more
attention grabbing you can choose a font
that really represents the brand but is
also a bit more stylized
a bit more decorative
when it comes to body copy we need to go
a bit more simpler for it this text is
usually in large paragraphs and it needs
to be easy to read especially at smaller
sizes and so for this one
choose this more simple
font for this and make sure you test it
at the smaller sizes too
so as a bit of a starting point of where
to find some fonts my go-to is google
fonts which some designers would be oh
but
it's free to use
these fonts they're small file sizes and
there is loads of choices over a
thousand fonts on there um and you can
narrow these down
as well
so good resource
so
we need this heading in this body
copy to work in harmony so how do we do
that that kind of comes down to the type
of brand or product or whatever that
you're working for
um fonts should kind of especially the
heading font should embody that brand
and or complement the style and tone of
that brand
if you have a tech brand for example a
font that has a nice modern feel to it
is good if you're working with a brand
for kids for example you might want a
more fun maybe rounded font for that it
just helps convey that brown tone
you wouldn't use say comic sans for a
really important warning sign
or would you
so i just want to show you some examples
of some good font pairings in the next
few slides that can help you kind of
make some of these decisions and i'm
going to use some famous nottingham
landmarks because that is where i am
from
um so here's an example for nottingham
castle
now this location has heritage it has
history so i've chosen that heading font
to kind of echo the type style of that
era it's got a good character to it and
it works quite well as that heading font
and the body copy font below is just
kind of classic serif font um it's
simple it's easy to read at small sizes
and they pair really well together
because of that
secondly
this is not in contemporary is an art
gallery
um so here we're looking at a kind of
modern style of font um here for the
heading it's bold quite eye-catching
again has some really nice character to
it um but it also represents a more
modern style of type like the gallery is
and i've paired this with a sans-serif
font so less decorative
this complements that modern style of
type again it's also really easy to read
once we go down to smaller sizes
and the last one here is attenborough
nature reserve so this is a kind of
nature center near me um so i've chosen
this heading style because it's quite a
fun display font it wouldn't work as the
body copy but it works great as headings
it gives that natural kind of feel
and then i've paired this with a serif
font here but equally i think this could
work with say the font from the art
gallery as well
because there is not one right answer
when it comes to design but there are
some wrong ones like that comic sans
example so it's just thinking about the
type of brand that you're working for
so to give your hand with font pairing
stuff there is a tool for that i have
lots of resources in this um so this is
fontjoy.com um it helps you pick some
font pairings and trial them um
in the browser before you go ahead and
kind of commit to
downloading fonts and all sorts so great
tool for that
so say we've got our font pairing chosen
now what do we do with them well we need
to set up some styles
so headings you've chosen your font
let's
let's set up our heading styles now we
need to
keep that hierarchy principle in mind
when we do this
so i've got two examples here of how you
can do that using the same font
our example on the left it just uses
scale
here to achieve that level of hierarchy
heading one obviously being the largest
and going down but our example on the
right also shows how we can add a little
bit more interest
again we're using the same font we're
just styling it slightly differently we
have one in italics we have one in all
caps with a bit more letter spacing
there
um
so
let's have a look at body copy now
body copy is slightly easier to get
right
usually i pick a kind of regular
paragraph size to use
but also it's good to set up a larger
one as well
and we can always add more styles um as
we need throughout the design but giving
yourself a good starting point here is
good
so when it comes to setting sizes and
scales another resource here uh type
pythonscale.com
this again lets you set a kind of base
level um and helps you scale up those
headings but you can also
um have a look at what your body copy
sizes are like so another great tool to
experiment with
so now we've got our fonts and we've got
our sizes the last thing we need to do
is figure out how we set the spacing now
this sounds really boring but it's
really important
and it's often overlooked
so firstly line height so this is the
spaces between continuous lines of copy
here i've got three examples kind of
goldilocks situation here to show the
line height examples
on this end of the scale the line height
is very
small it makes the text really difficult
to read everything's bunched up together
it's not enough
and sometimes our default line spacing
can look like this and we need to adjust
it
on the other end of the spectrum is this
the line height is huge my old design
mentor used to tell me off for doing
this and said you could fit a bus
through those lines
um again in a different way it makes
this harder to read you have to cast
your eye down further to find the next
line
so
middle ground of our two examples this
is a bit more like we want to aim for
and there's enough space to make it easy
to read
on there
the space that we don't use is just as
important as the space we do so it's
important to get that right comes down
to that proximity principle things are
too far away from each other they don't
belong in our brains
and secondly is paragraph spacing so
this is the spacing before and after
paragraphs
so here we have two examples
the one on the left is a bad example and
the one on the right is more along the
lines of what we want to achieve
so
on the right are spacing between the
paragraphs
and after the heading should be about
the same
this proximity
makes it so that these things belong
together with enough pause between
paragraphs
and then after the paragraph
that just needs to increase a little bit
more so that we can separate these two
paragraphs um here but also have the
headings
belong to those paragraphs of text
we compare this to our example on the
left we can kind of see why that
spacing's so important the proximities
are all off and
who knows what belongs to what um on
that example there
so it's really key to helping users
digest content if we think about that
proximity principle
so
we've got some typography examples under
our belt
let's move on to the next design element
so that's color
so
what i want to talk about today is tips
around how to create a color palette
to use across your design
so similarly to our fonts you might have
a bit of a starting point with a color
palette you might have an entire one to
work from but you might be stuck with
nothing
scary
so how do we choose colors
my tip is to start with one
because choosing an entire color palette
from scratch can be quite daunting
if you have one you can start to build
on that from there so the main color
that you
want to choose here is the one that you
would mainly associate with the brand so
you know easyjet is orange
uh delivery's got that teal
o2 blue for example
so once we've got that we need to create
uh two color palettes here similarly to
our font choices pick two
um a primary palette and secondary
palette and by primary palette here i
don't mean primary colors
i mean the most used colors throughout
your design
and secondary palette will be less
commonly used and more supporting colors
and so the best way to kind of
demonstrate this i think is just to show
you a real world example
and how that's used so i'm going to show
you uber's color palette
so this is their primary color palette
it's three colors it's black white
and blue
um so the black and white are chosen uh
they are good pairing because they're
quite contrasting colors and that means
they can be used together quite easily
and remember that contrast was one of
our design principles
that we touched on at the start so this
is a great way of achieving contrast
through color
so it's important to consider that when
creating your palette they also have
this third color the blue
i would call this an accent color
and but this is used quite frequently
throughout the brand but in a very
considered way
they say it's
called safety blue
so it's mainly used to highlight where
there's features messages alerts um or
things that they really want to
highlight essentially
so here's an example of that in action
so the example on the left is
from the uber website
they use that black and white
for good contrast in the text and the
way they section out the site but then
that blue is used there to kind of
highlight the real key kind of offerings
and draw the eye down there
and on the right is the uber app don't
look at my uber rating
that you mainly uses again the black and
white for contrast um but that little
dot there is set in the blue to really
grab your attention and tell you that
you've got a
message so this is uber's secondary
color palette which
you might think that doesn't look like
uber's colors
but they're used a lot more sparingly
around the brand especially in their
illustrations which is a big part of
their branding
and they're chosen to work alongside
that primary color palette quite well
so here we can see the colors and shades
thereof being used to communicate
through illustration
the palette is
used not only for contrast but it does
help to find that hierarchy as well
the secondary palette is supporting
elements
and the primary palette is the main
interface so that is a hierarchy in the
way that color is used
they never really deviate from these
colors
um and that's what keeps the brand
recognizable um a small set of primary
colors followed up by a larger set of
secondary colors it's a solid approach
to creating a color palette um
and that's what keeps their brand
recognizable
so
it's also beneficial to add some neutral
tones um this can kind of help add a bit
of layering and depth
um i don't know if you can see this much
on the screen but uber do use this in
their app um
yeah it's a little hard to see on here
these are very very light neutral tones
but they use some shades of grey um
to help kind of show where there's areas
of interaction
and this is something that you can do
neutral doesn't necessarily just mean
kind of
grays either this could be kind of
shades of colors that's used
in your brand palette so don't be afraid
to use kind of shades throughout as well
so choosing colors yes i have a tool for
that one as well
this is adobe colors
every designer will use tools like this
to help
choose colors
and this one's great because you can
kind of set that first color
and start to define some palettes based
on the tools that they have here um you
know you can try trial colors
monochromatic different shades um it's a
great tool for that there is also
another one i love called coolers dot co
um this is a bit more random but you can
create some really interesting palettes
on here and lock ones in
it does also have some other good
features you can upload a photo you can
generate a color palette from that so if
you see a color palette that you really
like out there take a photo
you can explore gradients in this as
well
but the other good tool it has is a
contrast checker for
accessibility so i know as developers
you'll have a lot of technical
accessibility standards to me
as designers the lowest bar to get right
in terms of accessibility is getting
colors right
um
you know it's easy if you don't have an
impaired vision to believe that certain
color combinations are fine um but we
just need to ensure that there's enough
contrast there
so coolers has a contrast checker but
this is the one that i would typically
use um to test out colors
um
it lets you kind of set the foreground
background color
and see what kind of standards that they
pass online um
there are a lot of other people who
speak in a lot more detail about
accessibility but i thought this was
quite important when it comes to talking
about colors
to touch on this point as well
okay let's discuss
imagery so i want to break this down
into three areas um i want to briefly
touch on photography illustration and
iconography
so let's start with photography
i'm just gonna have a drink sorry my
voice is a bit croaky too
typical
um so with photography
again it's possible that you've got
something to start with um so it's
important to ask yourself some questions
here
um if you've got some photos already are
they high enough quality and i'm not
just talking about the resolution here
um i mean just the photos themselves are
they good enough
um and do i need to add any more um
you know do i need um to
have more imagery that's more
appropriate here and where am i going to
source that from
um
as well as that you might be working
with photos from a database of some sort
so like product photos user avatars user
generated content
and in that case you don't have as much
control over it so we need to think
about the kind of treatment of those
images and how we put them on the page
as well
so it's important to take stock of where
you are to begin with
now speaking of stock
if you feel like you need to add more
photos to your project you can
commission a photographer you can take
some yourself if you feel like you're
skilled enough to do that or you can go
down the route of stock photography
um it's quick it's
cost effective um and you just need to
make sure that you're using license
photography you don't want to get into
trouble for copyright and stuff
um but it used to be quite costly to get
hold of stock images not so much anymore
there are some free resources out there
again
these are two that um i've used quite a
bit in the past this is unsplash.com and
pixels.com
they have a huge range of images
so
hopefully you'll be able to find
something
appropriate for what you're looking for
and it's all royalty free as well
fantastic resources pexels also has
videos as well which is fantastic
a word of warning when it comes to stock
imagery avoid the cheese there is a
reason that a lot of memes originate
from stock images
so please avoid this stuff um at all
costs if you can
so say you've got some photography
fantastic
there is something else you need to
consider
how are you going to put these on the
page um it sounds odd but there are ways
of making your photos look a bit better
or more enhanced if you need to
so first is the framing of the image are
you going to crop these images
into portrait landscape square images
or perhaps some different shapes
this is a really important consideration
to make um not all photos work well in
the same frames
and crops so you really need to be
mindful of this
ensuring that that focal point of the
image is framed correctly it's a key
element to get right in your design it
comes down to that balance
framing done correctly can also add some
good visual interest so you don't have
to be limited to rectangles
if you don't want to be
secondly
filters effects editing of photos you
don't need photoshop these days to do
this either um
you know filters can add a bit of
interest to your photos black and white
it's quite classic approach um but it
can also add some consistency to your
photos so
i know
having organized events before you get
speaker photos from all over the place
and you want to make them quite
consistent you can apply a filter so
they'll all look a bit more along the
same lines
something here like this black and white
approach or maybe like a duotone style
is a way to inject some
colors from your color palette that
you've created as well
um it's a little bit 2015 spotify i'll
give you that but if you
if you feel like your photos need a bit
more interest you can experiment with
filters there it's not a necessity but
something you might want to experiment
with
so that's photo based imagery but let's
have a think about illustrations
so
before thinking about illustrations as
an option it's important to understand
whether they fit into your brand style
it's quite a modern uh thing these days
um but it might not be appropriate
but if it is something you want to do um
usually there's kind of three options on
how to source these similar to
photography
so you could do it yourself feel like
you're skilled enough it's good you can
create illustrations without barriers
and it is quite a good financial choice
you can commission someone else to
create them now this is a great option
it's more costly but it'll give you some
more bespoke imagery and you can set a
brief so it's quite unique to your site
too
and lastly just like photography there
is stock sites um to pick up
illustrations too um
you know there's packs you can download
um some you can customize yourself too
so it's worth taking a look at the
options there
so one really great resource for this is
blush.design
it's predominantly people orientated
illustrations but it combines resources
from a lot of different artists and so
they're not all kind of the same here
and you've got customization options too
um you could download them in svg and
png as well there are paid and free
options across this site
so lastly under imagery i'm going to
touch on icons
so iconography age old way of
communicating we see it in everyday life
on signs like the exit sign in print
and digitally as well uh icons are just
simple symbols to help point us in the
right direction
and the benefit of using them it gives
immediate context uh to the content it
sits alongside um and in digital design
you'll typically see
it accompanying an action or a link an
alert things like that
so i just want to give you a couple of
major tips when it comes to icons
because it's not really rocket science
but there are some really common
pitfalls
um so the first is
only use an icon when it's obvious
enough what it means
it's very easy for us to assume that the
user will know what an icon
is going to do because we know what it's
going to do and i'll show you an example
of this
so these are some typical icons we might
see across the web
they're very familiar
and users will typically understand the
meaning of these
those three lines it's gonna bring up a
menu
magnifying glass will represent a search
and the bin is probably gonna represent
a delete action uh on there
so these are common icons that we all
know the meaning of um and we will call
these universal
icons
now let's consider what these icons
might represent
so these might not be as familiar might
not be as obvious in what their actions
mean and while they might be a good
representation for the context they're
in
it might be hard for the user to
understand the intention
so that heart could mean like
or it could mean add to wishlist
the second one that could mean a repost
or it could mean a refresh
um and that last one
could be a link to an faq it could bring
up a live chat um
so
if an icon is not clear enough what it
does give it a label
and that is my big advice when it comes
to using icons
it's also good for accessibility to
label icons as well
especially if they're not described very
well
so my other tip when it comes to icons
is
just keep them simple um icons need to
be used at small screen sizes
and that is where detail can really get
lost
typically icons are quite void of detail
for this reason they use just enough
pixels to communicate the point
so if i take it back to that search icon
from before it's a very very basic line
icon
to represent a magnifying glass
but it can be recognized at loads of
different sizes especially small sizes
because of its simplicity in design
that is the making of a great icon
so of course i have a couple of
resources for icons this is not an
exhaustive list but
a couple of good places to start
so font awesome is a resource that
offers a huge amount of icons that can
be used as svg or font files as well
um they offer free and paid packages
and their library grows every year so
there is a huge amount
on there
and then the noun project is a library
with loads of different contributors so
there's a lot of different styles of
icons there
again they offer free and paid packages
too
and they can be downloaded in svg or png
format
so
that's imagery
let's have a look at the final kind of
area
of visual design elements
and that's layout so this is where we
start putting elements together
this is where we really have to think
about our design principles
um when we start creating our designs so
i'd like to touch on two areas
today which is grids and component
building
so
um i'd like to start with grids here
so a grid is a solid foundation for any
page layout gives you kind of
coordinates on where to put things on a
page
typically good to use a grid um that is
divisible by different numbers which is
why a 12 column grid
is great and my go to for the web
divisible by two three four six
one in itself i guess um so this makes
for quite a versatile layout when it
comes to creating components
and once we start looking at responsive
design as well
um helps us adapt for those smaller
screens
so here's a typical 12-column layout now
i know this is not a revolutionary
concept um to those uh in development
and front-end um it is less uh even less
so of a modern concept in design um grid
systems have been around for designers
since you know books have been being
printed and so we're really familiar
with this kind of column structure
but i wanted to discuss this today
because it's very relevant to that point
of balance and that principle that we
spoke about before
really gives structure to your layouts
and assists you in maintaining that
balance and proximity as well so just
some examples
so these this shows how we can use a two
column section
now imagine what these squares could
contain
um it could be two of the same component
two images two columns of text two cards
um or it could be an image on one side
and text on the other which is kind of
that asymmetrical balance that we spoke
about at the start
uh it doesn't really matter the contents
and what we have here is a guide on how
to create that balance in the layout
again here we could have a layout with
three columns again it's
still got that symmetrical balance it's
got that invisible line down the middle
um just gives us the option to add
additional elements
we've got four column layout here which
is probably my favorite because it's an
even number so when you start scaling
that down you kind of can have a two by
two grid
um and you can have a six column grid as
well so
this kind of layout works well if you
have smaller features to pull out um a
grid of icons
works well in these kind of narrow
narrower columns
so i can't really stress enough how
imperative grids are
it gives you a clear guide on where to
place elements and it's where i will
always start um when working for the web
so we've got a grid fantastic uh let's
talk about the bits that go in those
squares um so i'm going to call them
components and what i mean here is where
we start to build out bigger kind of
elements of the interface
so
when we want to build up a page it is
best to start small
and build up from there um components
are built up of smaller pieces and often
can form repeatable elements that we we
can reuse throughout page as well
so to kind of go through this i want to
briefly touch on a framework called
atomic design
so atomic design is a framework used to
help us break down a layout into smaller
elements um the methodology uses the
following kind of items to describe how
to build a component
so we've got atoms molecules and
organisms
and that builds up into entire page
designs but what does this mean in terms
of ui
so atoms
these are the most basic building blocks
of an interface the kind of singular
elements
so in terms of the web this could be a
label
it could be a text input
or it could be a button
so like atoms in nature
these elements are important but they're
not always super useful on their own
they need to kind of merge with other
atoms to become something bigger
so this is where molecules come in
so molecules are where two or more atoms
combine
in order to create part of the interface
suddenly that label that text input
or that button from before
combine to become a search bar
so as you can see once we start
combining these smaller elements we can
start to make bigger parts of the
interface so this is a molecule
um it helps to start at the bottom
not getting overwhelmed
so from molecules then we can move up to
uh
organisms
so in a similar fashion
organisms are made up of two or more
molecules
so that search bar was a molecule
and that combines with other atoms or
molecules and we can start to build out
a header menu here
so we've got a logo we've got text links
we've got that search bar you might want
to add additional items here such as a
basket link or account for example
but what we're doing here is just
starting to build out those bigger
components those organisms
but starting with the smaller blocks
um so again this allows us to think
about repeating and reusable elements as
well
for example
uh this is an example
of a molecule we might typically see on
a blog um i'll call this a blog card
and this
is made up of atoms
so the atoms that make up this are the
container we have an image we have the
badge for the category publish date off
their title description and button these
are all little ah little atoms try
saying that three times um
that make up that molecule um so when we
have these
molecules we can start to put them
together to make organisms
so here's one that we created just by
repeating that one molecule element and
just changing the content there
so from there you can start creating an
entire blog listing page
um
and it just goes to show how those tiny
elements can be built up to create
larger ones
if there is one thing that you take away
from this talk i want it to be this
start small and build up from there
designing a whole page can be really
scary but designing a button is a good
first step
um
so before i move on to the kind of last
section
i just want to put the atomic design
resource up here because i heavily
lifted from it and condensed it into a
couple of minutes um
so
you may have heard of it it's a
by brad frost i think it started off as
a blog post originally um but it's now a
book and a website
and it goes into a lot more detail about
how you can build on from those um
atoms molecules and organisms as well so
please do check that out
so
the last section here
um
what i wanted to do with it i originally
was going to attempt live design um but
i've done this talk in the past and it
was not a good idea
um so i want to show some examples of
how we can refine existing designs um
say you've started something and you're
just not sure that it's quite right it's
not quite polished
to a good point i want to kind of go
through some before an example before
and after examples um here to kind of
explain
how we can apply those principles and
those design elements um across that so
let's begin
so
i want to start here with a card um so
this is quite similar to our blog
example in some ways
um but here we've got a house that is
for sale
um so we've got all the information we
need on this card um
we've got the price
the location
we've got a bit of the spec
we've got an image gallery there as well
but what we're really kind of lacking
here is some good hierarchy
and balance in that layout so
how can we improve this
so uh
our example on the right
both of these cards contain pretty much
the exact same information
um and they perform the same functions
and but there's big differences in how
that's communicated just from the way um
that we've adjusted the layout
um price
we've identified that as the kind of key
element we need to pull out here it's
the biggest thing
that needs to be on there thinking about
the hierarchy here
so
let's make that big let's make it bold
let's make that
pretty much at the top of the card for
the gallery
now let's think about condensing some of
that clutter down
from the left-hand example
we've used icons here and in the context
they're in they're pretty obvious we
probably don't need to label these
here and that helps us kind of achieve a
nicer balance across this
card
lastly contrast and i don't know if you
can see this too well
i tried to up this from last time but
the contact information there for the
agent we've put into a slightly neutral
tone there
and we've used a slight bit of contrast
there to highlight that information
um
on there and we've also pulled out the
logo of the agent just for a bit of
brand recognition as well
so
the last thing that we've done here
is
um we've adjusted the gallery controls
um on the first example they're kind of
hidden away
in that corner they work
they're okay
but on the other example here
what we've done is we've placed them in
the context they need to be we've placed
them over the image on either side to
indicate
that you're flicking through images
and we've also put the indicator in
there of how many images there are
really just gives the user an idea of
what's coming
so small adjustments there but it's big
change
okay let's look at a pop-up so
this lesson is mostly in hierarchy but
also a little bit of
um kind of veering out of my lane here
um but with this example on the left
what's our problem here well this is a
destructive action
and the warning for this is super small
at the bottom it says it's irreversible
um also the buttons here they don't
really have any differentiation
um to make that decision at first glance
so there's a lot of mental load for the
user to kind of do here
so how do we improve this
so let's make that warning a bit more
prominent um
and let's accompany it with an icon to
show that this is important another way
to kind of show hierarchy here we've
placed it first and we've added a bit of
visual interest there
to
indicate that this action is
irreversible
secondly
let's look at the text that's used in
the buttons here
rather than saying yes or no let's make
those actions a bit more obvious
um we'll have delete for the destructive
action and cancel for the other and i've
swapped these around as well um it's
quite a good idea to have your main
action on the right hand side
in cases like these is typically where
that goes
so
we've also considered the contrast and
the hierarchy in the way that we've
styled these buttons as well
um so one is filled in and it's also red
uh helps indicate the nature of that
action
um and the second reaction there
it's outlined and it helps give a bit
more contrast to that primary action um
for delete there so
again
just adjustments that we can make that
can help the actions for the user be a
lot clearer um
these two boxes do exactly the same
thing but
one is just improved
in helping communicate to the user
so our next example here how do we make
radio buttons look a bit more
interesting
so
our example here let's consider the
hierarchy um
so
what is the biggest difference between
these choices well if we look at them
it's quite obvious that they are data
plans um
and the big differentiator
the big differentiator that the person
designing this probably wants to
highlight is the amount of data
that the user is going to get so let's
make that the biggest thing um let's
make that really clear in our options
let's keep the price uh standing out a
little bit let's put that in bold um but
ideally we want to show the difference
between the plans
so secondly
let's put them into these nice big block
components um this creates a nice sense
of balance in the layout we do have that
on
the one on the left it's just visually a
bit more interesting
um
and it helps separate them out a little
better than that radio button
uh lastly our selected state um this
invites a big level of contrast um and
more so in that tiny little radio button
we've got now we have it in a big block
so it's really obvious to the user what
choice has been selected which might be
really key in a choice like this where
you're signing up for a plan for example
um
so simple incremental changes again
enhances choices like these where it
could be a monotonous form
just makes the user's experience
slightly more enjoyable
here is an example of how we can add a
bit more interest in a simple block of
text
so this isn't a bad example by all means
but we can
just tweak it a little
so our improved example on the right
here
here we've chosen some slightly
different font weights for the headings
we're trying to add a bit more contrast
here and highlight what's important
the body copy color that we've chosen is
also slightly lighter than our headings
just makes those headings stand out
again a bit more
if we think about proximities
our example on the left
it's a little more condensed in how the
text is laid out so
in our improved example
we've taken a look at that spacing that
line height that we spoke about at the
start
and we've adjusted that to suit a bit
more
lastly we've added some icons here
instead of some basic bullet points
especially when this is kind of a
step-by-step process it's quite nice to
use um some icons for example
or numbering here to help that just be a
bit more clearer
neither one of these is wrong
but i know which one i probably prefer
um so this is my arch nemesis when it
comes to design it's a table
these can be really boring and as a
designer you never want to get under the
table to apply design to um but there is
ways that we can improve them
um
so the best way to improve these is to
start by looking at the actual content
in the table um and understanding that
um are there any columns that we can
perhaps combine can we
uh get some space within here
um let's look at the actions if there
are any well there's two at the end
there are they particularly clear
probably not in this example
so let's see what we can do
and i hope this looks okay on this
screen
it doesn't
but um so how do we make this a bit
nicer so first i've considered the
context here
so what can i combine well that name and
that customer number there can be
combined um in this instance
um i know that the plan and the price
can also be combined they're not
typically
bits of data in this table that we're
going to need to differentiate and you
may need to ask around for people to see
if that's right
um but here we've also added a bit of
contrast and so we've picked out what's
the most important bit in there
in this case the name and the plan name
within there so again a bit of contrast
to make that clearer
um
it's a good tip if you're using bull to
highlight something that's great as long
as you have a regular weight to contrast
against
um if everything is bold then nothing is
bold so make sure you have a couple of
weights
set up in your fonts
so then we look at the status
let's introduce some color here let's
indicate the differences between these
statuses
um
color isn't always enough either you may
have people who can't perceive color
like you can
so we've also accompanied this with some
iconography to help make that visually
clear as well you know approved has got
a tick a waiting approval a little timer
for example
um
so another way of adding a bit visual
interest here
and i've got a bit more space now that
i've condensed those columns down so
let's look at those actions
um i've put them side by side rather
than stacked um and again we've
introduced some icons here
it helps the user understand what those
actions are going to do
and i've introduced colour into that
delete action
and it's quite a common thing to do and
it helps
show where that destructive action is
finally i don't think you can see this
very well i've kind of uh reduced some
of the harsh lines um from the first
example
tone them back a bit and what i've tried
to do in this example is make every
second line a slightly different color
it helps guide the user's line the
user's eye across that line so that they
know they're on the right row
so again both of these tables do the
same job just slight differences in the
design
uh my final example uh here um i wanted
to include a cat somewhere in this
presentation
so this is the kind of hero section
header area of a desktop website
so here
we've got an image we can use we've got
a title and description we have two
buttons
and we also have the menu to think about
so again this example is all right
but i can't really see the cat that's
kind of important so how do we improve
this example
so the biggest thing for me here is
around the photo that's used
the one on the left uses an overlay
which is fine because it helps the text
become a lot more legible um but it
obscures the photo
so
we've got to think about that kind of
framing um of photography like we spoke
about earlier
and luckily this photo has quite a solid
background behind it so what we've done
here is we've moved the image onto the
right side and extended that background
and used that to create more contrast in
the text text is
definitely a lot more
easy to read especially that body copy
um within there in fact we've been able
to reduce the size of that because of
the contrast given
um
overall we've got a better crop of the
image as well we've kind of got that
asymmetrical balance with the image on
the right side and the text on the left
um
then we have our buttons underneath so
small tip for hierarchy and buttons
um if there are two together it's good
to make one of them look different
especially if one of them is a primary
action and one that you want the user to
choose more
so here that's clearly the adopt a cap
button that is the one that they
will want people to click more um so
we've made that um the filled button
and the outline button there is the more
secondary action and the filled one um
adds a bit more contrast so the user's
eye is drawn to that more
and finally i've looked at the menu
itself um not a lot of change here but
we have included
similarly to the example on the left we
do have an overlay but this time we've
used it for the menu and we've also
again looked at the hierarchy of links
in this section so that donate link
wants to have a little bit of contrast
we don't want it to conflict too much
with that
with that button in the hero so we've
just pulled that out into yellow button
there
so again
it's small changes
um in design
um but it can make a big difference
whether it's a button or block text or
larger areas of the design
so that is all we've got time i cut a
lot of stuff from this presentation
turns out an hour it's not all that long
um i had a lot more fonts and color
um white space as well um but if you've
got anything that you're working on
um or if you want any sort of tips or
advice from a designer today you can get
some free advice
so please do come and find me
i'll be milling about um after this um
and i'll also tweet out this slide deck
in fact i think it is my pinned tweet at
the minute um so all the links to those
resources are available on my twitter
thank you very much